До війни підприємство Наталії займалося виробництвом жіночого, чоловічого, дитячого одягу.
Головним продуктом компанії були вишиванки.
Тепер швачки перепрофілювалися - замість вишуканих сорочок відшивають
спальні мішки для військових.
Все, що ми зараз робимо - підсилюємо в тилу голками хлопців на війні.
Наша зброя - це наша машина. Спальники були одним з того, що необхідно для людей,
щоб нормально функціонувати. Спати - це важливо.
Наталія працює в бізнесі легкої промисловості вже 20 років.
Жінка швидко зорієнтувалася, як перелаштувати процес виробництва,
закупити потрібну тканину, налагодити поставки.
На її підприємстві на Волині спальники шиють приблизно 30ть людей.
Команді потрібен був час, щоб призвичаїтися до виготовлення нового продукту,
а також керуватися міркуваннями практичності, а не краси.
Важко. Завжди, коли запускається новий продукт, до тижня часу, воно не дуже добре працює.
А пізніше всі вже звикають. Хоча в нас.. Розумієте, у нас речі, які йдуть з душею,
вони трішки інші, вони робляться повільніше, туди вкладається позитивна енергія.
А спальники - це процес повністю. Для нас безпосередньо це було дуже складно.
У нас інша тенденція, ми повільніше працюємо над кожною річчю. А зараз у нас це масовка.
Компанія Інни Делії з Полтавщини до війни виготовляла столи.
Більшість клієнтів були з Києва і передмість - Гостомеля, Ірпеня, Бучі.
Вже понад місяць ці замовлення не актуальні. Тож вирішили всі заготовки металевих ніжок
до столів віддати теробороні - з них тепер роблять протитанкові їжаки.
Згодом Інна вирішила, що слід перепрофілювати виробництво і виготовляти те,
чого потребують захисники країни - бронежилети.
У нас був запит на бронежилети. І ми розуміли, що наше виробництво підходить
по обладнанню для бронежилетів. Тому ми знайшли ГОСТи бронежилетів,
розібрали їх до молекул і намагалися зрозуміти, чи можемо потягнути
нашим підприємством виробництво бронежилетів.
Половину колег Інни мобілізували. З рештою жінка виготовляє
приблизно 40 бронежилетів на день. Коли захисний засіб створений,
його не відправляють на фронт, поки не протестують на полігоні.
Інна каже, що хоч з військовою тематикою раніше ніколи не стикалася,
досвід виробництва металевих ніжок для столів допоміг жінці
швидко налагодити виробництво.
У мене були всі контакти постачальників, постачальники металу.
Тому мені було легше знайти метал потрібної марки для бронежилетів.
І у мене є зварювальники, які мають досвід з металом, тому це взагалі не проблема.
Ми дуже швидко налагодили лінійку виробництва, і нам дуже допоміг попередній досвід.
Переорієнтовується також і харчова промисловість, як, приміром,
цей японський ресторан у Львові. Для армії тут тепер виготовляють
ситні азійські перекуси – онігірі. Після того, як спустошили ресторанні запаси продуктів,
звернулися по допомогу до волонтерів.
Дуже багато волонтерів зі Львова почали приносити дуже багато продуктів.
Рис мішками, багато консервованого тунця, свіжі овочі. Ми за день зібрали близько 80 кг рису,
нам цього вистачило без проблем - готувати такі ось трикутнички
для наших хлопців з Києва і Харкова.
Сергій розповідає, що спершу їх критикували, мовляв, навіщо годувати
військових японськими стравами. Однак адміністратор каже, що така їжа
містить баланс вуглеводів, білків і жирів, а отже корисна і поживна.
До того ж, такий снек практичний - його можна покласти в кишеню
і перекусити в дорозі, якщо зголоднів. Партії онігірі кожні два дні відправляють
військовим у Київ і Харків. А для львівської тероборони ресторан готує повноцінні обіди.
За свої послуги ресторан коштів не бере.
На даний момент є така ініціатива від наших власників, що ми протягом 3-5 місяців
не обговорюємо питання будь-якого прибутку для нашого ресторану,
тобто ми готові протягом цього часу допомагати нашим ЗСУ.
Ще один спосіб допомогти під час війни - це працевлаштувати біженців
з інших регіонів України. Адже їм теж потрібно на щось жити.
У команду Сергія взяли двох переселенців з Києва.
Наталія Ярош теж працевлаштувала дівчину з Василькова, що на Київщині.
За словами жінки, співпрацювати з людьми з інших регіонів країни - це не тільки допомога,
але й корисний досвід для компанії.
Я вам чесно скажу, що з біженцями це навіть дуже цікаво, тому що досвід інший
на нас накладається - це дуже непогано.
Наш обов'язок на сьогоднішній момент, мене як керівника, забезпечити роботу
моїх працівників, партнерів, які збоку. Проплатити податки.
Тому що якщо я не буду робити, хтось не буде робити - це біда.
На підприємствах, які на кшталт компанії Наталії перепрофілювалися під потреби армії,
переконані, що навіть за умов війни вони повинні працювати.
Адже це підкріплює тил і також наближає Україну до перемоги.